hello believe nation
I made the mention e-series to try to
hang around and spend a little bit more
time with people who've done a lot more
than us and hopefully their mind says
the ways of thinking some of they're
bullies kind of seep into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're going to learn from Eckhart
Tolle on the power of now motivation and
as always guys if Eckhart says something
that really really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
could be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
you
at the eagle of course looks for
liberation from its unsatisfying
unsatisfactory state it looks at the
Eagle knows this is what it knows
something is missing
but it always looks in the wrong place
as we already said it looks there but
never here so it never goes deep into
life into what is it ignores the simple
reality of the present moment and looks
inland that towards the next moment for
satisfaction for the that which I can
add that will make me complete hence its
obsession with future with the next
moment and hence everybody lives that
way almost everybody as if the next
moment were more important than this
moment and this is that strange it's a
form of mental illness because the next
moment doesn't even exist except as a
thought in your head it's the only
absolute reality that future has is it
exists as a thought in your head and it
is fine as for practical purposes it's a
helpful thought that there is such a
thing as future because it enables you
to make an appointment so it's helpful
we got here because of future because of
this thought that there is such a thing
as future but there isn't because nobody
has ever seen it or touched it or
experienced it and since nobody has ever
seen touch to experience it we can
assume that it doesn't exist and
obviously it doesn't because when the
future comes it's a now the next moment
comes that you wanted to get to and
finally you get there and it turns out
it's the now again
and the ego runs away from it not
realizing that what it has been looking
for is hiding here no matter what form
this now takes it is hiding where the
conditioned mind which is the ego has
never really looked it always made them
now at best into a means to an end
okay this now I need this now because it
enables me to get to that more important
moment which is the future okay a
stepping stone best of times or the ego
had reduced the now to an obstacle in
some people some people that is their
normal existence they could every day
long every day long whatever comes into
the now this is an they look at it as
well an obstacle get out of the way I
want to get there every every person
that comes in no I want something else
the ego always wants not this it wants
to use this to get there
it wants to use every person that comes
into now to get there so every person
the ego means okay are you going to
enable me to get to the next more
important moment how can I use you to
get where I want to get to the now is
making to an obstacle or for the people
who are very strongly very strongly
identified with the egoic mind they make
them now into an enemy continuously
complaining it's never enough they
should why don't they this never well
they can go into the most wonderful
place and after five minutes they found
the one thing that's not working as
should and they're complaining um yeah
they should do something about it if not
I'm going to do something about it and
if they are not complaining verbally
they're complaining in their heads
complaining about situations about other
people about what's happening or
complaining it's something that should
be happening is not happening this is
see it sounds insane because it is
insane
but it is not record nothing personal it
is not recognized as insanity because it
is fairly normal and if it's normal then
it's not recognized as an illness so
that is the dysfunctional state of
consciousness that is condemned to
perpetual discontent how do I you know
it seems you try to stop thinking but
and you read all this and you try to
practice it but yet in any given
situation I find that in order to get
closer to practicing it or even practice
it it's causing a lot of thoughts to
happen so it's a different kind of
thoughts or those thoughts that I should
break that kind of habit and if so how
okay thank you thank you
now the that there's a lot of talk these
days about not just talk actually it's
happening addictions many people are
dictate to all kinds of things
substances but one of the greatest
addictions or one of the greatest
addiction never actually you never write
about it in the papers because the
people are addicted to it don't know it
it's the addiction to thinking it's
actually addictive can't stop thinking
it's like can't stop drinking can't stop
smoking can't stop eating can't stop
thinking think
is the greater addiction they're not any
of these and it's an addiction because
its first it's been a drug Monster has
been around for so long and it's a
pseudo sense of self so it's a great
reluctance on the part of most people to
let go of thinking because [ __ ] is
equated with the state of sleep through
let go of thinking there isn't that much
to understand in this teaching there's a
little bit to understand about how the
ego works but even that is just mainly
not self observation the main thing
about it is presence presence and
presence is this place of no thought but
presence can also be there in the
background even when thinking is
happening you can still be not
completely involved in the thinking
thinking loses the ability to create
havoc in your life and confuse you so in
your choice then is not to understand
more or to bring some intellectual
analysis to the practice but to practice
the state of not thinking which can be
arrived at by various ways as you
probably know if you don't think about
it just do it becoming more aware of the
present moment and accept it as it is
slows down the overactive mind is one
thing because a lot of the older
activity of the mind is an attempt to
get away from the Isthmus simplicity of
the present moment so to become more
aware of the present moment as a
practice have perhaps little pointers in
your office at home in your car
let's say present moment or whatever or
symbol for it and add different entry
points into the present moment present
moment awareness means thinking subsides
may not disappear completely
but something else arises that is
primary we call it presence or awareness
Buddhist solid mindfulness which I don't
use because it implies if your mind is
full of things it isn't of course it's
just a mistranslation so that to be
present first of all use the present
moment to become but how do you become
conscious of the present moment now when
you get it after a while you can you can
actually sense the presence of the
present so to speak directly in there it
is but helpful things our sense
perceptions take you out of thinking if
you are not judging the sense
perceptions labeling naming looking
around anywhere wherever you are look
around
practice sense perceptions without this
compulsive interference of naming what
if what you're perceiving oh that's a
beautiful flow I wonder what it's called
I don't know what it's called well that
helps I can be free of thinking if I
know what it's called I can say oh that
such-and-such and then drop that and see
what it means to perceive without the
interference of concepts words at this
moment for example you're looking at me
now let's say between now and now why
are you thinking no okay and
between now and now were you thinking or
present no thought and while I speak do
you need to think to understand what I'm
saying or can you just listen and
understand it and this is what you're
doing and so let's part of the teaching
and the function of the spiritual
teacher imparting information is
secondary what I'm telling you now is
secondary what is primary is the
underlying state of consciousness which
is presence that's the teaching but you
can't talk about that
it's underlying but the sign that it's
working is that while you listen there's
no thought there's just a large presence
and when the throat
teacher stop speaking for a moment the
alert presence remains it does not need
to be filled with anything like now what
is there to think about
nothing now if we do this for longer if
we at some point your mind will probably
start up and think how much longer is he
going to sit then
and when that happens you can allow your
mind to see how much longer is he going
to sit there and say nothing and then
come back to presence and then some
other thought will come what is all
about and then you can allow that sort
arise and then be present again which
means you're not really your priority is
no longer to follow the thought where it
wants to take you because the thought
has a magnetic pull it wants more of
your consciousness it wants to grow
because it's a little entity it wants to
grow so it wants to your attention in in
subtle ways it tries to get your
attention says it might even use a
bodily feeling says because I'm hungry
suddenly why didn't I need to eat
something and when you think of a rep
motorist and I'm going to afterwards and
so the presence is gone you are gone you
are looking for restaurant in your mind
which means the thought used as some
bodily thing to make thoughts out of it
completely pointless because you can't
find the restroom because you're
standing here but it can use all kinds
of things to manufacture most to get
your attention
and if you're not careful if you don't
know the mechanism it's not so much an
intellectual understanding but a simple
realization that this is what the mind
does it tries to pull you in it's fine
it's what it does once you know that you
can allow soar to rise without following
it where it wants you to go which is
into another bigger thought and a bigger
one so then you become like like my dog
when it finds a scent and then suddenly
in the dope when the dog is off Elyse
usually she's fine she just runs around
you but suddenly she picks up a scent
and then she goes off completely unaware
of surroundings or anything you just
follows it
and she could get lost she goes off to
the horizon sometimes just disappears
and that's when you follow a thought it
goes like that you can wake up 20
minutes later and it started with
lasting a little bit hungry and thinking
of a restaurant and it ends up we're
thinking about how ungrateful your life
is I find myself fluctuating between the
path to spirituality and wanting more
material wealth are these paths mutually
exclusive your feedback is much
appreciated fluctuating between the past
of spirituality and wanting more
material wealth all these paths mutually
exclusive
if material wealth becomes your primary
aim then one could say they are mutually
exclusive
but if you engage in some activity that
you truly first will truly enjoy enjoy
doing and secondly if that activity that
you engage in and enjoy doing make some
contribution some positive contribution
to this world to the planet to other
human beings as something valuable to
life increases perhaps consciousness on
the planet then if those two things come
together then you may find that as a
by-product of that activity some
material wealth also comes to you and
there's no reason why you cannot enjoy
certain forms material form whatever it
is that come to you and you enjoy that
you may have to give away some of that
and it's enjoyable to and and you mean
if beautiful things come or bigger
things come the enjoyment of a beautiful
thing or a house or even a car it's not
necessarily
non-spiritual the attachment or the
excessive preoccupation with it with the
attainment of it that is not compatible
that it takes you away from reality the
truth of who you are from awakening but
you can be quite present and in touch
with that which is beyond form and
nevertheless enjoy forms that come to
you not in an obsessive way of wanting
to accumulate as much as possible of
this or that but enjoy what comes
without identification with the forms
that come the house the car whatever the
material thing may be so in that sense
they are not incompatible renunciation
which traditionally is recommended as a
path to awakening is not the true
renunciation is not really renouncing
material things its renouncing
attachment or identification with
because many people traditionally in in
management in many cultures and
religions who have renounced material
things didn't realize that they had not
renounced desire in their mind so they
suppress they try to suppress desire and
by having no possessions and refraining
another particle of course pronunciation
would be celibacy for example refraining
from sexual activity as part of
renunciation not realizing that they
have this they spend last part of the
day thinking about sex
so yeah that outer renunciation is not
really the main thing the true
renunciation is attachment to which
operates on an inner level so you can
have a very poor person being attached
to their few possessions very strongly
and seeking identification through that
you could have a very wealthy person not
being attached to anything of course the
other way around can also be the case so
it's the inner that matters and whether
or not you are attached to some material
thing you can usually often become may
not be able to really tell it until you
lose it oh it breaks and so it's always
good little test when something leaves
you or is stolen or breaks or destroyed
if then upset arises anger or whatever
then oh I wasn't touched I thought I was
not but when you can let go when things
come and let things go perhaps things
come to you and perhaps after a while
you give it to somebody else to enjoy
that's that's appreciating beautiful
thing things that you the sense of
ownership also begins to disappear so
you look after something for a while and
then it's handed on to somebody else
there are quite a few people who do not
express emotions fully or don't express
them at all
perhaps even more so in northern
countries the further north you go
unless they express the emotions that's
how it seems to be maybe it's too cold
to express your emotions now the
practice I describe of observing your
emotions allowing them to be for
somebody who habitually does not express
emotions it is not usually the best way
to try and observe his or her emotions
because they may not even know what the
emotions they are having they may be so
much pushed down so particularly for
those people have been suppressing
emotions it is very helpful to express
the emotions if possible without
injuring anybody or yourself to allow
yourself to express emotions and witness
that at the same time the expression
itself would not free you because
emotions if they are not observed and
not witnessed tend to renew themselves
through renewed thinking because there's
a special circuit with emotional thought
processes so the expression alone is not
enough because you would simply be stuck
with it and express the anger because
the anger dissipates somewhat as you
express it but if you are not conscious
of the relationship between your thought
processes and the anger the thought
processes will create renewed anger and
so you would be going to the same or
other therapists and hitting the pillows
for twenty or thirty years not realizing
that through your thought processes
you're continuously recreating emotion
and you
identifying so much so without the
presence expression is better than
repression repression can make you ill
but to become to transcend it is
essential to be alert and present and
watch it as an energy field so that
through the watching it becomes
depersonalized so that you don't feel
you're not totally stuck in it and then
you can express it hit something not a
person if possible the pillow if it's
anger or scream and feels good perhaps
and feel the raw energy of it like fire
ah feel it Wow and if you allow it
completely and express it it can even
very quickly turn around and then you
can do something useful that you have in
enormous energy and suddenly it gets
turned around and it's just it's no
longer it can shift from anger to just
being intense energy okay now I'm going
to clean my room not angry angry anymore
simply with energy you could also clean
your room still being angry but that's
not good cleaning because you would be
cleaning on the material level and you
on an energetic level you would be
polluting your room and so to become
free expert for a while some people need
to express fully and then a time comes
when there's enough presence and you
have expressed it then you can gradually
more and more work on the inner level
and bring presents to each on the inner
not that you ever hold it down if it
wants to it needs to express itself you
may do something maybe you can transform
it into physical move
and vigorous movement or whatever it is
and watch but always be there as a
witness at some point you may you have a
find that you have a choice the emotion
arises you can express it or not express
it and you can simply be transformed or
transmuted through bringing presents to
it you will know in the moment whether
it needs to express itself or not if you
have never already expressed emotion
then by all means allow yourself to
express it without indulging and without
personalizing it recognizing it as
energy no more just energy and watch
what happens when you pay attention to
the way in which you interact with
objects and what is okay to use every
minute of the day this you pick
something up you put something down you
unbutton your shirt you you take off
your shoes you lift this put this there
open your bag zipper back II you look
inside take something out can you feel
it as you take it out can you feel the
texture of that and then you put it on
the table it makes it sound as you put
it on the table and then you have a
glass of water and the light is
reflected in it and it moves
perhaps you drink and it tastes that you
put it down again and then you look at a
familiar object instead of using it as
always as a means to an end here you
have the luxury of occasionally just
taking an ordering object that you
handled every
I am just a few seconds give it give it
attention and acknowledge its being just
as that as that object just feel it see
it makes it as it makes a noise as you
put it down and again you bring in sense
perceptions getting dressed in the
morning putting pants on they make a
noise as you put them on a little bit
yes do things you pick up the tools
placed you hold it for moment put the
cap on the sink click then turn on the
tablet and then while you brush your
teeth you turn off the tap because you
don't want to waste water but but that's
not part of the exercise
and it's you can actually begin to like
and to enjoy the tiniest things around
you that would normally be completely
overlooked the essence of the way in
which you interact with the world of
objects and that brings a richness into
your life that doesn't depend on how
many objects you own you don't need to
own them to interact with them and so
here you acknowledge their beingness and
you sometimes you might just put your
hand as I'm doing out here's a table
it's wood and I'm putting my hands on it
and for a moment I feel the floors
texture surface of this table and it
feels very pleasant and I don't but I
don't need the mind to tell me that I
can I can sense that as the strange
thing is even so-called
inanimate objects in a strange way have
a life of their own as I'm awakening I'm
becoming more aware of how often I'm
angry and it is getting tiresome how do
I manage the expectations of myself well
it's the soul man that you need to
manage the expectations and then you
need to manage the anger anger
management and expectation management
expectation means you beat yourself up
for being unconscious which is more
unconsciousness
because the mental image of who you ask
us I'm not good enough I can't do it you
see it's been added for 25 years and I
still can't do it you can't possibly be
any good if you still can't do it after
25 years those are thoughts that float
around in your mind and how do you feel
as I suppose it's barn Katie without fit
how do you feel when you believe in your
souls not good you're beating yourself
up and you feel an emotion feel bad
about myself more ego more
conceptualized identity in your mind
concept in your mind about you you
derive your sense of self from that more
of the same so the let's say it's anger
the ekor and then you wake up after the
anger reactions I did it again I'm no
good so you have the second egoic
reaction to the first one anger is
something that is comes in in many
people very fast so there may not be
unless it's already considerable
presence power in you there may not be
enough presence to catch it it takes you
over before you know it
especially it's all reaction and before
you know what you're talking and
shouting and you are not doing it at all
it's a it's the pattern it's the the
mind pattern mental emotional pattern in
you which often related to what I call
the pain body which is old accumulated
painful emotion which could be anger
which could be deep depressed sadness
anger is a very frequent one as the pain
body energies just waiting in people
have accumulated old anger going back to
childhood feeling powerless and what is
it child to when the child feels
powerless start screaming it's all you
can do and sometimes it works sometimes
the parents come and say okay you can
have the sweet
if you scream loud enough so it's
powerlessness is always behind anger and
the ego pretends that there's your power
there in anger but anger Rises out your
sense of powerlessness and it's a so
they enters often fear hiding underneath
it and when you when you are there
looking at it then you can you realize
it at first hand within yourself taste
there is a sense of powerlessness behind
it and the ego is pretending to be
powerful when really it's in a state of
fear you can see these with little dogs
the smallest dogs are the most Barkley
most and whenever well they're little
I've seen littles little dogs when they
ever bake one goes faster get angry
because I mean if I were that size I
would do that too probably
so you are you are little chihuahua or
your little bit sweetly Bichon Frise and
and a mastiff box past or a Rottweiler
who looks very quiet because the
Rottweiler knows its own power
it doesn't need to because
[Music]
and the little one but with dogs we
smile when we see that because we
somehow recognize that pattern and we
smile and probably the Rottweiler has an
inner smile too when he walks past but
with humans it's more difficult it's
moment they go and word comes streaming
out of their mouth it's more difficult
to smile and but it's possible not
necessary you say that don't necessarily
smile but recognize it from what it is
when you see it in another don't equate
that with who that person is recognize
it that the person has been taken over
by that energy field and that already is
a wonderful thing that ready we could
call it forgiveness in a wider sense we
don't equate unconscious behavior with
who that person is if we equate it with
who that person is that is that's the
real meaning of judgment judgment is not
to say to somebody I realized that you
get angry a lot in that person then
might tell you are you judging me no
it's a fact if I see that you get angry
a lot that was just effect there's no
judgment in it but if I equate that with
your sensual identity of who you are you
are an angry person in the next always
expect more anger from you that's a
judgment not recognizing a pattern that
operates unconsciously through humans
and taking taking therefore the identity
is judgment and you can do it yourself
you can judge yourself for those things
and that is just as much ego as
judging somebody else you can beat
yourself up and call yourself no-good
and whatever else the self-talk tells
you in your head it's it calls you you
infantrymen in many people's minds they
when they talked that the mind talks to
you it says you see you as Austin's
until you see you can't do it sometime
it says I might say I in some people but
in many it says you let strange you talk
to yourself in your head one part of
your mind condemns the other part when
you see it you can rise above it and
basis suddenly an awareness that comes
with it you're no longer trapped in
those patterns I would recommend
particularly to become particularly
alert where you know you're getting
stressed something a situation is
building up in some kind of for example
if you get anger takes over when you get
stressed could happen when when you feel
stress building up towards it you can
become very alert so that you can
doesn't take you over what you know the
anger is about to about to come or if
it's if you know certain areas of your
life are more likely to break your
conscious sometimes you know just
beforehand that yet those are going to
arise in the next minute or so and then
you can be a lard-filled entire energy
field in your body be a large it with
every cell of your body then pick up the
phone and talk about the financial
situation with your investment advisor
so that it's only treat those as
spiritual practices
and realized nothing is more important
than consciousness not the situation
that its consciousness
some people's plain bodies are consist
as I said predominantly of anger and you
can something some people you can sense
this the semi dormant plane body in the
background even when they are not
particularly angry right now but there
are people who are waiting for the next
opportunity to be angry that's their
pain body and sometimes when you when
you are sensitive towards other you can
feel energy fields you can sometimes
sense in other people they are waiting
for an excuse to be angry some of and
you look into their eyes it's already
there it's but it's not them it's let
which occupies the inner energy field
which the pain body and so they are
waiting and any excuse and they will get
angry at you or wherever it may be
so you become a grievance looking for
cause it seems to me is a general
pattern at work that it is inherent in
the nature of physical existence of
life-forms that challenges our essential
ingredient of their lives and here and
out of the way through which they evolve
but when they say they evolve rare means
is the one consciousness evolves awakens
into this dimension through the
different life forms in different ways
and it awakens only because we are being
challenged and that's already that is
quite a relief to realize to be
challenged doesn't mean is something
wrong
is something wrong with my life that
shouldn't be if you believe or act as if
this shouldn't be happening then you get
really unhappy then the challenges
become transformed into unhappiness
inside you you think it's not
unhappiness it's resentment if it's not
resentment it's it's anger its self-pity
it's complaining its despondency itself
for the simple reason that you are
misunderstanding the very purpose of
life and expecting something that your
mind has come up with it's so different
there is a source of power in you that
transcends the person and it's not egoic
power over somebody and it's one with
the power that is the power of life in
the universe where all life arises and
people sometimes have
problem with self-confidence or valuing
yourself and sometimes you try to
convince yourself by changing your
thinking that you are actually good
enough that you should be self-confident
but there is a better way to find the
source of self-confidence on the egoic
level self-confidence is there because
you see you can tell yourself I'm
actually more intelligent in most of
these people or I'm better-looking than
most I have to remind myself that I'm
better-looking in most of men okay I
feel a bit more confident now
or you say I've actually have more money
than these people so I should I have
more self-confidence whatever it is some
way of convincing yourself and then you
compare yourself with others and then
you focus in those areas where you feel
superior to others and try not to think
about other areas where inevitably you
are inferior to others because you
cannot be superior in all areas it's a
complicated game when you start start
comparing yourself to other people and
if you want to bolster yourself
confidence and you only have to focus on
where you feel I'm actually better than
most but that doesn't really work that
well so there is a better way of self
confidence that is nothing to do with
comparing yourself with others or with
feeling you're better than or not as
good as and that is direct access to
inner power you don't need any
comparison you can have it right now at
this very moment if you're not stuck in
your thinking mind but take your
attention a little bit beyond the
thinking mind and then realize that you
are the presence behind the thinking
mind without which there could be no
thinking you're the aware presence
behind it all and it is deeper you've
gone deeper into thinking mind and that
aware presence is where power resides
and it's not yours because it connects
you with universal power therefore you
don't need to compare yourself to
anybody anymore or feel as the ego
always does that you're either superior
or inferior
and somebody else that's a not a
comfortable way to live where you have
to classify yourself and you need people
and so you give the fears always I might
be inferior or behind that fear is the
desire to be superior conveying that you
communicate can be done in such a way
that you don't make the other person
wrong that is a very helpful thing don't
you
I was staying many years ago I was
staying with some buddies when I didn't
happen I was actually writing definite
limit applies to him starting the
beginning of the power of now somebody
offered me a room in his apartment
and he had three cars and he said you
can have one of them you can use it I
don't use it anymore he would always buy
the next more expensive car because he
got too satisfied with the old one so I
could got what one of the old ones that
he was dissatisfied was to drive around
and it was a beautiful car few years old
but I fought when I had one day I left
the car and there was a signal when I
closed the door but I didn't realize why
the sound was beeping
and when he realized he realized the
next day well I wanted to use the gain
in the end and wouldn't start so it
seems that the light stayed on the sound
was to advise me to the light but why
I'm telling you this is he had done some
spiritual work and I was very impressed
when he left me a note because he got up
before me he left a note which said the
lights were on and the battery got
depleted you need to call the triple-a -
that's more I was very impressed on it
not because he didn't normal the partner
had not done any consciousness work
would have had you left the lights on
despite the fact that you that we must
have heard the warning signs
so they well this person has some
awareness he's not making me wrong of it
was my mistake but he's not making
somebody else wrong in the service of
being more right than me could you
please explain what the divine purpose
of the universe's
[Music]
the universe wants to awaken
consciousness coming into that this
dimension is the divine purpose but the
divine purpose is twofold one is the
universe delights in creation it
delights in creativity its alights in
creating new forms how do I know that
well just look around on the planet here
the millions of life forms in the sea on
land the air it is the university lights
in in creating this multiplicity of
forms and it delights in experiencing
itself through all those forms because
you are not say separate entity it's not
the case as sometimes the ego ego itself
believes here's me and there's the rest
of the world of the universe or the ego
things that that it is in the universe
it somehow suddenly appeared fallen into
this universe and then where am I
obviously I'm in this universe you're
not in the universe you are the universe
the one life expressing itself through
countless life forms and there is a
growing complexity in life forms
and with every experience the universe
is experiencing itself as your life
extremely differentiated in human beings
the way in which life or the universe or
the one consciousness experiences itself
in this dreamlike world is extremely
differentiated it is amazing that every
human being is different of those
billions of humans on the planet every
human not only looks different you could
recognize if you know one person out of
these billions like I don't know how
many billions on the planet now you
could recognize this person
out of billions of other human beings
just by looking at their face this is
all differential it is of the surface
layer level already and then every life
experience of course there are many
similarities but there's a uniqueness to
every life experience of every life
strange is a world that arises and
subsides my mother's life were your
mother's life your parents life
anybody's life was a particular world
the way she experienced the world was
very different from the way I express it
like my mother and I and I'm just taking
one example from my personal experience
steam to inhabit completely different
universes but we were in the same place
but experiencing life in a totally
totally different way and the university
lights in that complexity of experience
so it wants to experience itself as form
it means install the forms become
evolving more more complex the humans
that are live now a far greater
complexity than the humans that were
alive ten thousand years ago or fifty
thousand years ago life at that time was
more simple get under food get of the
plants or hunt an animal if they were
did that prepare the meal go out hunting
I come back home it's very simple it
wasn't the complexity of New York City
LA freeways and all that that's behind
that could be the nuclear physics
whatever and so on and so the university
lights in that and you are an expression
of that it wants to become conscious of
itself through you and it's doing that
attempting to do that through humans but
you know that one consciousness is not
separate from you you are an expression
of it but the universe also wants to
know itself deeply its own source it
wants the source realization also so I
could I know that because I know it by
looking within myself there is an
outgoing movement into creation and
there is a return movement it wants to
realize itself in its essence the
universe wants pause it wants to go out
and create it once also wants to realize
its own essence through you in a human
life that expresses as wanting to do
things in this life wanting to
contributes to this life wanting to
create something to make something of
your life your so-called life it
expresses as that it is the other the
return movement so you have the outward
movement of the universe the return
movement expresses s coming totally into
the present moment stepping away from
becoming into being becoming is the
outward movement what can I do now I
need to do something I want to create
this I feel that this wants to something
coming through me I feel a piece of
music wants to come through a book wants
to be written or something whatever
want to do this I'll create this set up
this business or that or whatever and
then it's becoming doing but then
there's another movement excess I just
want to be and be still and this present
moment go deeply into this moment I
don't need to become anything at all I
just want to be fully who I am already
and go deeply into being so you have
it's almost this contradictory movements
in some humans the outward tendency is
greater in others the inward tendency is
greater both are necessary and some are
both need to be there as long as you're
here in the human form both to some
extent will be in you but there will be
different to different degrees some are
much more going within and to being to
the source but I would suggest that it's
not either/or there are certain
spiritual additions that look upon it as
most other or they say forget about the
world just realize where you are and
then you can just sit in a corner for
the rest of your life and never do
anything again you don't need to that's
one way but it's I for us it's finding a
certain balance which doesn't mean it
needs to be totally in balance there
very few humans who are totally balanced
between the outward movement of creating
and the inward movement or couldn't get
connecting with you with your inner
being and the source of all that you
need to oppose so that you the universe
can create through you without losing
itself in its creations so you can
create not from a place of egoic need
where you depend on the outcome if I
don't get that I'll kill myself
don't achieve if I don't get famous and
which I've done a model do not that but
a playful participation in the world of
form and and contributing to it to the
world of form without losing itself in
the creation and in the doing if you
become stressed means you're losing
yourself in the doing this is more
important and she completely [ __ ] you
become uprooted you are no longer
connected to the spaciousness the
unconditioned complement within so to to
be and do at the same time but some
humans yes are much more drawn to being
I call them frequency holders they hold
the frequency of being on the planet
they they're not interested in creating
huge things out there the interesting
doing perhaps little things gardening
cooking looking after animals being with
animals helping humans in some capacity
helping even physical helping humans dep
with their bodies and so on so their
frequency holders they're more to being
and they some doing but you cannot use
have to do something you can't do but
until they don't put the emphasis on
doing the emphasis on being and then
they allow presence to flow into what
they do and they affect the world also
very significantly others have a greater
tendency to performing creative action
they need to go out and become active
but their challenge is not to get lost
in what they do in thinking that's all
important they forget that this is a
play of form and then there comes the
seriousness into heaviness into the
doing
and they get unhappy and we are unhappy
whatever you create has some flavor of
that unhappiness so the divine purpose
of the universe to summarize my long
explanation is to know itself all
through the creation of form and through
realization of the formless essence of
life and that is the divine purpose of
the universe and that you are here as
part of that thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what did you think of this video
what was the message that resonated the
most with you what did you learn from
this that you're now going to apply in
your life or your business please leave
it in the comments below I'm going to
join in the discussion thank you again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon